der winterhimmel in der neujahrsnacht
generiert von zehn video biemann und
hochleistungscomputern im zeiss
planetarium in berlin
die weiten des weltalls werden gerade
auch 2018 gründlich erforscht geben uns
die sterne auch ein wink wie es
persönlich weitergeht
anders als die astronomie vermutet dass
seit jahrtausenden die astrologie 2018
steht im zeichen der venus
das heißt dass alle menschen darauf aus
sind sich wirklich verstehen zu wollen
und auch nicht dauernd gegeneinander zu
kämpfen also das ist das jahr der liebe
der sinnlichkeit der schönheit das heißt
ja heute werden alle die gelegenheit
bekommen ihre eigene venus stark in die
richtung in zusammenarbeit zu gehen und
sich zu harmonisieren
aber es wird im neuen jahr nicht nur
harmonisch sein
der planet uranus könnte für turbulenzen
sorgen
wir haben noch eine extreme
konstellation und zwar wechselt
tatsächlich auch noch der uranus in den
stier
das heißt diese stier konstellation in
der uranus der eintritt gibt es eine
kleine revolution
also es ist sehr gut möglich dass der
euro da ins wackeln kommt das ist die
große frage wie lange der dann macht
also mit sicherheit wird er auf jeden
fall noch bleiben knapp ein viertel der
deutschen glaubt an die stern deutung
bei wichtigen persönlichen
entscheidungen werden die sterne befragt
wenn der astrologe gut analysieren kann
dann ist das so eine art lebenshilfe die
man verwenden kann um auf einige
situationen vielleicht besser einzugehen
spirituell und religiös geprägte
menschen blicken übrigens mit zuversicht
in die zukunft so neueste umfragen der
berliner buchladen dauert leistet dazu
einen beitrag
hier gibt es ratgeber tarotkarten oder
räucherwaren um zuhause böse geister zu
vertreiben
man kann das leben nicht zurückdrehen
aber man kann am jahresanfang kann man
neu anfangen
in was für einer art auch immer also ich
beobachte dass viele leute gerne mal so
ein hausputz machen ausräuchern da
gibt's hier diverse stoffe dem mond wird
eine magische kraft zugesprochen aber
auch steine nach meinung mancher können
sie sogar heilend wirken überhaupt
gesünder leben ist der klassiker unter
den guten vorsätzen für das neue jahr
obst und gemüse stehen zu jahresbeginn
hoch im kurs
ich denke es ist auf jeden fall sehr
wichtig auch für den körper und immer
schön fit zu bleiben obst und gemüse ist
immer ein ziel faktor im laden
ein weiterer guter vorsatz mehr sport
nach reichhaltigem essen zu weihnachten
und silvester wollen viele abspecken
einige stecken sich noch höhere ziele
sport im neuen jahr sehr wichtig denn
ich habe mir vorgenommen ein marathon zu
laufen und um das zu schaffen treibe ich
verschiedene sportarten
das start-up erben sportsclub vermittelt
seine mitglieder an verschiedene
fitnessstudios besinnliche ruhige
weihnachtszeit ist zu ende
dementsprechend dem sich viele leute vor
jetzt was für die gesundheit zu tun sich
mehr zu bewegen und entsprechend merken
wir das natürlich bei den anmeldungen im
januar/februar 44 prozent der deutschen
blicken einer umfrage zufolge
optimistisch in die zukunft viele haben
vorsätze oder konkrete wünsche ein
bisschen mehr frieden dass ich gesund
bleibe meinen job behalten
die liebe findet vielleicht mehr reisen
ich fände es toll wenn ich weniger
kaffee trinke ich will weniger in den
sozialen medien unterwegs sein aber das
ist schwer
welche vorsätze und wünsche sich 2018
wirklich erfüllen
das steht in den sternen